so uh now that the republican national
convention is underway
which will include the formal
renomination of donald trump as the
republican nominee for president
uh accepting formally whoa my chair
almost just fell
uh accepting formally on thursday
something stunning is going on
the republican party is surrendering
to whatever the hell trump wants and
republicans have announced
they are not going to be adopting any
platform at this week's convention
instead they're saying we support trump
now some of you may know if you've seen
conventions before
it's not only typical but it's really
one of the key things that is done
at a convention which is that the
candidate is nominated
but platforms for the party are voted on
and established they're updated every
four years the platform
is modified as makes sense four years of
stuff
has happened now what is really
hilarious is that republicans are saying
you know because of the social
distancing stuff because we're doing
everything safely
we're just not going to do any kind of
platform update and we're essentially
pledging allegiance to whatever the hell
donald trump wants now
there's something very interesting and
specific to this year
policy and platforms are a problem
when donald trump is your nominee
because you've had
four years of doing absolutely nothing
and in some cases supporting ideas
that run counter to much of what the
republican party actually has stood for
on paper so republicans have decided
we're just not going to unveil a new
platform period and hilariously they're
saying that
it's because the event is scaled back
that they're not going to do it the
truth is if they wanted to unveil a new
platform
there's nothing stopping them from doing
it uh it's the speeches that have to be
scaled back or at least the crowds the
audiences
the in-person stuff but a new platform
could be developed it could be unveiled
regardless of the format and instead the
republican party is pledging to quote
enthusiastically support the president's
america first agenda this of course
is extremely unusual and even some
republicans are saying that the party is
essentially abandoning its values
abandoning its principles in order to
support
donald trump and that is indeed exactly
what they are doing i mean the
republicans willing to say that are
correct
they've completely abandoned all of
their stated values and they're just
saying whatever trump wants he gets
elected republicans and the republican
party are descending
into the same cultish behavior that
trump's followers
have fallen into and this is typical
of authoritarians around the world we
talked earlier about don jr speech
where it's trump alone can fix it trump
is the pr you just you just have to
follow and support trump
policy is irrelevant all that matters is
everybody get in line
and support the dear leader and it's
another
step in the direction of
authoritarianism where there is no
tolerance
for critical questions the group leader
is always right
the way to know the truth is to ask the
leader
what does the leader think and the other
thing republicans are probably
too dumb or too distracted to realize is
that by
not changing their 2016 platform they
are conceding that trump has
accomplished accomplished nothing and
i'll put it a different way to make it
really clear
they claim and trump claims that he is
the most accomplished president in
history they say and trump says about
himself
i've done more in my first term than any
president in history
and yet their plan for the next four
years
is the same as for the last four years
if the plan is the same
you didn't do the things you said you
were going to do
if you succeeded you would want a
different list of things for the next
four years
it's all incoherent and and i'm
obviously trying to apply logic where
there is no logic
but this is fundamentally a cult that
now extends to the republican party
itself
of people who are either too afraid to
go against donald trump
or simply don't care as long as they own
the libs and so they're going to scrap
their platform
put aside everything they claim to stand
for and let trump ramble for four nights
in a uh possibly uh i mean just
historically laughable and humiliating
republican national convention
and important always
he could get another four years if we
don't act to prevent it
he could end up with another four years
make sure you're following me on twitter
at dpakman and make sure you're getting
the daily audio podcast
on whatever is your favorite podcasting
platform